the final trailer for it chapter 2 has
arrived and it looks even more
terrifying than the first film here's
everything in the trailer you might have
missed
the trailer opens with the voice of Mike
Hanlon the same character that narrates
the Stephen King novel on which the it
movies are based grown-up Mike is now a
librarian in Derry and has spent years
collecting information about the town's
dark history his expression in this shot
from the trailer along with the siren
lights on his face suggests he's at the
scene of one of penny wisest crimes
there's another allusion to the recent
bout of violence in this wall of missing
children signs in Derry
it seems Mike will be instrumental in
getting the group back together to
destroy the creature once and for all
when mike says lady knows he's reminding
the group of their collective vow to
destroy it if he ever resurfaces and
Darren I swear I swear if it isn't dead
if it ever comes back we'll come back to
later in the trailer there's the shot of
the whole group linking hands which
closely resembles the oaths making
scenes in the first film maybe they're
renewing the blood vows they made 27
years ago in the books whenever it
returns to dari his murderous rampages
usually began with someone in the town
committing a terrible act the run of
violence in chapter 2 begins with a hate
crime perpetrated against Adrian melon a
young gay man who's attacked and thrown
into a river as Pennywise awaits him
from under a bridge
it looks like the film changed the
setting of Adrian's death from the
bridge to the sewage tunnels in response
to the news about the creatures return
the losers Club comes back to Derry
reuniting over dinner at a Chinese
restaurant this meal will probably add
the same terrifying way it did in the
book and the 1990 miniseries with the
group opening fortune cookies filled
with terrors notice that there's one
person missing from the dinner table Sam
in the book Stan panics when Mike tells
him the news about Pennywise returning
to Derry overcome with fear Stan decides
he'd rather die than face the clown
again shortly thereafter his wife finds
him in his bathtub having cut his wrists
in the shape of a tee and written it in
blood on the bathroom wall a grown-up
Stan does appear in it chapter 2 played
by actor Andy being so the film likely
will show the characters grisly death
probably as one of its opening scene
it's possible that this is Stan's
lifeless hand shown dripping in blood in
the trailer the trailer indicates that
one of the main events in chapter 2 will
be the Derry town carnival which finds
Pennywise in his natural habitat as a
clown
the teaser trailer released in May also
showed Pennywise at a circus but
apparently not in clown form more on
this in a bit at the fair bill follows a
little boy into a maze of mirrors to
stop him from falling into one of Penny
wises traps this sequence inside the
funhouse may be a reimagining of a scene
from the book in which bill meets a boy
in Derry who reminds him of his younger
self that would explain the symbolism of
the mirrors replicating Bill's
reflection all around him there's also a
scene that apparently takes place in a
mental hospital if this part is true to
the book then the resistant patient you
see here is a grown up Henry Bowers the
sociopathic bully who was only slightly
nicer than Pennywise the first movie
left it unclear whether Henry actually
died when he fell down the well
[Music]
one moment that also appeared in the
teaser trailer was this scene of Beverly
trapped in the Derby school bathroom as
a stalled it's inundated in blood the
imagery here closely mirrors Beverly's
first encounter with it in that scene
from the first movie Beverly heard
voices calling out to her from
underneath her bathroom sink when she
peered in to investigate more and more
blood began to emerge from the sink
eventually flooding her back er it looks
like Beverly would go through a similar
ordeal in Chapter two but this time in
the school bathroom a traumatic place
for her as she was bullied there in the
first movie a number of shots show
grown-up bill reliving the trauma of his
youth when he returns to his childhood
home and stands at the site of his first
encounter with penny wise his younger
self appears behind him haunting his
memory pen you eyes is also torturing
bill with visions of his younger brother
Georgie who the clown killed at the
beginning of the first film bill still
grapples with an intense sense of guilt
about his brother's death he's always
felt responsible because he helped to
make the paper boat that penny wise used
to learn Georgie toward the sewer in the
trailer Georgie appears in the same
yellow rain jacket he was wearing when
he died
[Music]
this shot of an emotional Beverly may be
from the beginning of the film when she
decides to leave her abusive boyfriend
and join the rest of the group in Derry
we also see a shot of the three doors
from the first movie each bearing a
different label scrawled in blood
very scary scary and not scary at all
bill and Richie came across these doors
inside the decrepit house where they
went looking for Pennywise it's clear
from the trailer that that house will be
the setting of important scenes in
Chapter two behind one of them was a
dismembered Bettie rip some the Derry
girl who disappeared into the sewers the
trailer closes with a shot of Pennywise
looking strikingly human with the facial
features of actor bill skarsgård clearly
recognizable the only other time
Pennywise has been shown in a remotely
human form was in the teaser trailer in
this photo on the wall of Beverly's
childhood home the photo ostensibly
belongs to the old woman who lives there
a mysterious figure who calls herself
mrs. Kirsch
what did he do mrs. Kirsh my father but
if this photo is real and Pennywise was
at one time a human who joined the
circus
then the film would be departing from
its source material in a big way
according to King's novel penny wise is
a demonic force from outer space the
tonton dairy every 27 years since a town
was built in 1715 so will it chapter 2
changed the creatures origin story and
could this shot be a flashback showing
penny Liza's final transition into it
form will have to wait till September 6
to find out did we miss anything let us
know in the comments